Lindsey Graham said as a part of his
critique of your performance that you're
more scared of the NSA than you are of
Isis is that true you know I think there
are people who you have to consider the
source you know this is a person who
said that he would use censorship if he
needed to this is the same person who
said well when people ask for an
attorney you should tell them to shut up
this is the same person who's also said
that you know you know they ask for a
judge just drone them I mean some of the
stuff I dig doesn't rise beyond sort of
middle school kind of rhetoric and so
it's hard to know when to respond to
people like that but I think ultimately
if you want to talk among adults about
is Isis a threat to our country yes is
NSA a threat sometimes to our Liberty
yes I personally don't think you have to
trade one for the other I don't think
you have to trade your liberty for
security I think you can have both I
think the Constitution can be a powerful
tool the Constitution never said we
wouldn't go after records of criminals
or of terrorists Constitution just says
you have to individualize the suspicion
put a person's name on it I tell people
I want to collect more records of
terrorists just less records of innocent
Americans